ça lui le là je t'appelle en direct de
l'idaho je vais te rappeler twin falls
d'accord tu me manques embrasse joseph
cua
et ça va ouais ça va il devra écouter le
conseil de maman marché face aux
voitures quoi tard quinze ans ok j'en ai
45 alors je sais ce que je fais compris
on suis pas si sûr c'est pour ça qu'il a
[Musique]
je m'appelle jo belle eux
je marche pour le changement je traverse
les états unis appuient pour dénoncer
l'intimidation
je suis harcelé par des gars à l'école
pourquoi dis moi parce que je suis
différent deux sites c'est pas une
réponse c'est de nous seuls à briller
on va laisser la nature suivre son cours
et ça va bien aller ça va s'arranger
tout seul tout cas ça s'arrangera pas
tout seul mon fils de 15 ans s'est
enlevé la vie parce qu'on l'a intimider
c'est votre faute vous saviez qu'il
souffrait et vous n'avez rien fait
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur la
route seul avec moi-même certaine prise
de conscience en était difficile soit
pris dans des corps la jolie vue
[Musique]
sont toujours la présence de jay de nu
je croyais que dans la nature t'aiderai
à sentir comme un homme ça veut dire
quoi pour toi être un homme j'avais peur
pour toi on avait tous peur pour toi
[Musique]
de quoi
j'ai dennis avait au moment de sa mort
que vous l'aimiez ou l'acceptiez ce qui
compte le plus vrai suis jamais dit que
c'était pas grave mais je dois vivre
avec ça
je crois que je peux plus continuer je
veux rentrer à la maison si tu marches
pour jaden c'est lui qui tire à quand ce
sera le temps de rentrer à la maison
peut-être puis si tu marches assez loin
et assez longtemps tu vas me retrouver
j'ai laissé tomber mon fils et je ne
pourrai jamais me faire pardonner
s'il ya une chose que vous devez retenir
celui
de prendre soin de ceux que vous aimez
et de les accepter tels qu'ils sont
parce que vous pouvez les perdre à tout
moment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]